not this much
so uh good morning to everyone uh in the
audience here at simon's institute and
uh on zoom
and uh
this is uh welcome to the theoretical
speaking
lecture
okay um
so welcome to judy apparel who's going
to talk about the science of cause and
effect from deep
learning to deep understanding and we
are extremely lucky to have you that
join us today even if remotely uh i
guess i want to give you some
instructions before we get started
um because it's a hybrid event
right people uh war and zoom
should type answers in the q a people in
the auditorium can essentially raise
their hand when there's a question and
answer period or i believe that if you
just speak up if there's something
unclear judo probably won't mind
and
i am shafi goldwasser i'm the director
of the institute and which is an
international venue for collaborative
research in theoretical computer science
and
fields uh joining fields and we were
established in 2012 from a very generous
grant from the simons foundation
we bring together people from computer
science from mathematics from
engineering from biology physics
[Music]
neuroscience and and more to really
explore the use of algorithmic thinking
in science and in engineering
and uh as you know this has become more
and more relevant over the last decade
and uh one of our explicit goals is
actually to expand the horizons of the
field by exploring scientific
disciplines through what we call the
algorithmic lens
and today's lecture is part of our
theoretically speaking series which
highlights very exciting scientific
fundamental
and computational advances for a public
audience
and
judah is the chancellor professor of
computer science and statistics at ucla
just down the coast where he directs the
cognitive system of laboratory and
conducts research in artificial
intelligence human cognition and
philosophy of science
he has authored several uh books um
among them heuristics in 1984
probabilistic reasoning in intelligent
systems in 1988 in causality in 2000
2009 which won the london school of
economics lackato's award for 2001.
and more recently he co-authored casual
causal inference in statistics
and
which brings causal analysis to general
audiences pearl is a member of national
academy of science national academy of
engineering and a fellow of cognitive
science society
the royal statistical society and the
association for artificial intelligence
advancement of artificial intelligence
and in 2011 he won the touring award for
fundamental contributions sort of filial
intelligence throughout the development
of the calculus for probabilistic and
causal reasoning and in 2022 he wrote he
won the bbva award uh foundation
frontiers of knowledge award for laying
the foundations of modern artificial
intelligence so computer systems can
process uncertainty and relate
causes to effect and in particular this
talk is particularly relevant to our
semester because we have a semester
right now at simon's on causality and
learning and then many many visitors
whose i think careers and
professional interests were affected
directly from uh yuda or judah apparel's
results so
i'm going to pass you the mic uh or
virtually you da in welcome and please
uh the floor is yours
well
thank you very much jaffee for
introducing me
it's a pleasure for me to address the
simon institute again
last time i visited you
it was in
2013 i believe nine years ago
and the setup was a bit different
i talked in your auditorium
and i had
it wasn't on zoom
i remember vividly the car being in the
first row and papa demetrius
but
we will get used to the
zoom
media
okay
my last time last time i talked here
my title was the causal reasoning or
causal inference
this time i elevated here to a level of
a science
with something which i discovered
recently
we are sitting on a science not just a
bunch of algorithm
and that is what i will try to
convey to you today and i'm going to do
it in a context which is
quite
hot in the discussions today
it's the
tension
that takes place in data science between
the data and the science
mainly
the difference between deep learning and
what i call deep understanding
and i would like to convince you
that we have today
the computational facilities
to
model
what we normally call deep understanding
my agenda
will be
outlined here
i'm gonna talk about the reason
that gives me the audacity to call
this venture the science
and
i'm talking about what makes
science the science
and here i'm gonna within this uh
paradigm
i'm gonna talk about the two fundamental
laws of causal inference
ci
will be my symbol for causal influence
where i'm going to show you a ladder of
causation which is a hierarchy of
reasoning which came out of these two
fundamental laws
and which some people call the dna
of reasoning
within that
because rather
we will find
a
do calculus which is an algebra of
interventions
which is a working host of many of the
applications which i'm going to discuss
in number two and what will be the
applications
replication will tell us
what the new science can add to ai
three bullets
one is combining
data
with prior causal knowledge it looks
reasonable
but it has
faced a lot of
difficulties
to combine
data with prior knowledge
and prior scientific knowledge primarily
and second will be seven pillars of
causal wisdom
i call them pillars
and
what they are
are tasks that can be accomplished today
and that we couldn't uh accomplish
until
two decades ago okay
so it gives me a sense of accomplishment
and a sense of joy
we can do things today that we couldn't
do yesterday and that is
the fun of doing science
uh then i'll talk about two horizons
which i believe will be the directions
that causes inference will take in the
future
it's just barely sketched now
one is personalized decision making the
other one will be social intelligence
okay we have the agenda and now it is my
obligation
to fulfill all my promises
[Music]
i'm going to go to a data science domain
and tell you about the clash a real
clash
high
highly hot confrontation
between two aspects of this
data science
one is the data and the other one is the
science
well in the scientific paradigm
we have
up
what am i doing here
here we are a scientific paradigm
is characterized by two
notions
number one one a world number two a
question about the world
namely we ask ourselves
what should the world be like
before we can answer
a research question
but the results question is not about
the data it's about the world
these two notions will be missing
in the
alternative paradigm
which is i called data centric paradigm
where
there is no such notion
as a world outside the data and our
task is
to fit the data as well as we can so as
to to maximize
some measure of success
measured on what
on the training set on the data itself
because since there is no
model of external to the data
all we can do is to try our success on
the data
and this is our measure of success and
this is constitute
a measure of performance okay
now
okay let me now
go deeper in what i mean by a scientific
paradigm yeah
especially when we talk about
understanding
our
focus will be the notion of
understanding under what condition we
can say the system understands
when we look at what we people mean by
understanding
one important characteristic that should
not be underestimated
is the sensation of being in control
it's one of the
most powerful
force the drive behavior
for human being and for children
uh
my
even psychologists or
psychological
um
[Music]
therapeutic
clinical
psychologists will vow to you that they
drive to be in control
is immense
for instance battled wife
fall into the illusion that it's their
fault and they are trying to improve
their behavior and
please their abuser more and more just
for the sake of being in control
they cannot change the behavior of the
abuser so they change themselves in
order to feel in control to make a
difference to have the
illusion that they're improving that
they're doing everything that they can
in order to improve the situation so i'm
i'm not going to focus much
on this psychology
of battled wife and children
but we are going to go into formalizing
that notion of being in control
what can we expect from a person
who
feels in control
number one we want that person or that
machine
to be able to predict future events from
past observation
you are
uh
watching
uh
uh
say
you are watching uh
a thousand by thousand
um screen
of pixels and you are trying to predict
the label
that is attached to
that
the interpretation of the screen whether
it is a tiger or a cat
that's a
highly complex example
of predicting one event or one label
from past observations
then you want to predict the consequence
of actions
actions by definition
are something that make a change in the
world
and you turn the light switch on
and
you expect to see
uh light in the room
the child rattle the play
and expect to find
the sound
of the rattling
okay so predicting the consequence of
contemplating action
next level
you like to provide
he who is in control
could provide explanation
for unanticipated events
if you turn the switch on and the light
does not come on
then you strike do you need to explain
or we expect that understander
to explain whether it is
a burned light bulb
or perhaps a power
surge
in the network
and to be able to repair it and the
reason we want to find explanation
is to repair
and get things
uh under uh back to normal
fourth the imagine alternative world
or also called roads not taken
for instance
we can say what if
cleopatra did not have the kind of
beauty she possessed
how would history of western world
change
i'm going from history to something
more
banal
what if i
i didn't do what i actually did what if
i acted differently
so i imagine roads not taken
and reason about them
why because of that ability to imagine
imagine
gives me also the power to form new
theory and to discover
new
ways of handling things
so this is the kind of level we are
going to talk about we want to be able
to
implement on a machine
in order to
qualify
for the title
understanding
the fifth one which is still in on the
laboratory
bench
uh ideas of uh
conducting new experiments seek new
observation these all
follow from number four
and i want to focus on the
idea of curiosity
because this is an element
which we find
in human being
not so much in
low-level animals
although some people tells me that the
raven have some capability
of curiosity what we mean by curiosity
curiosity is a
restlessness
that a child exhibit
when the child is learning
a new phenomena for instance why one toy
rattles and the other one does not
and the discovery is that one has a
moving ball the other one does not have
a moving battle now the interesting
thing is
that children
when they learn
by playful manipulation
a children
are arrestless
even if they do not
receive any
award
even in a reward neutral task
they are restless and try to
please themselves and achieve a level of
understanding that is a feature of
humans which
clearly distinguish them from a monkey
and the other lower level animals okay
the
desire to achieve a level of
understanding or level of being in
control
regardless of whether they receive
reward
for that understanding
so what does it take
i took i
accompanied each one of the bullets here
with a simple example
taken from everyday life
but i would like to impress you that we
are talking about highly complex
endeavors here not as simple
as
turning the light switch on
here
are practical cases where
are in need of understanding
for instance how effective a given
treatment is to preventing a disease
for instance
a manager can ask was it the tax breaks
that caused our sale to go up
or a marketing campaign extremely
important to be able to
decide
which department deserves the next
budget increase
what is the annual health care cost
attributed to obesity it was in the news
lately
whether we can even quantify the idea of
a
health care cost attributed to obesity
can hiring records prove an employer
guilty of
sex discrimination
extremely important in our days when we
talk about the fairness of algorithm
fairness implemented in ai system
or even a legislating
algorithm
making sure that they are fair okay
question regarding personal decision
making now
i'm about to quit my job
will i regret it
given that i am about to quit my job
provide some information about how
pleased i am with my job and whether i
will regress
so
now
notice that i've highlighted in yellow
uh
five
notions
of relationships
and the reason i labeled them i
highlighted in yellow
is number one
they give me the clue that we are
dealing here with a new specie
of computation
i can recognize them from a distance
because i
trained myself in the past few years to
see them in every sentence that i read
and also
because they have
a special feature
they cannot be
articulated
in the grammar of ordinary science why
they are unarticulated in the standard
grammar of science
because that standard grammar
has been
handcuffed
by a symbol of equality
by
equality sign
which is an algebraic equality
if y is equal to ax when x is equal to y
over a
algebraic equalities do not distinguish
directionality
and we are dealing here with a
asymmetric relationship of cause and
effect it gives you an example
that if x is the atmospheric pressure
we expect the deviation or the
deflection of the barometer
to be enslaved
to follow the atmospheric pressure
and
you and i would agree
that it will be
unacceptable
to say that the atmospheric pressure
follows
the
deviation of the or the deflection of
the barometer
so
all this
highlighted notions are asymmetric
and
when we talk cause of fat relationship
we are talking about this asymmetry
and
we must
we must
resign
to the fact that science has not been
gracious to us to provide us with an
algebra
to handle this asymmetry
so we must
invent a new algebra to capture this
asymmetry
in this important notions that
that
colors or shape our understanding of the
world
in computer science we do have an
operator
which can capture that
asymmetry
we call it assignment and i'll show you
uh how
we
give
we interpret
things in the world in terms of
assignment that nature assigns value to
other to uh
variables or to events okay
based on the notion of asymmetrical
assignment
so
we'll go to there but a little bit of
history
because i should pay
tribute
to the first person
who noticed
that science has not been
gracious to us
and decided
to invent a new notation
for the asymmetry that we find in nature
and this was civil right
a geneticist
a geneticist
in the 1920s
who dealt with the
hereditary phenomena of guinea pigs
he fell in love with two things with the
guinea pigs and with the
causal relationship which he puts in
path diagrams
what did he do what did he accomplish
he was concerned
with a lot of hereditary
to what degree the fair color
of the parents guinea pigs determine
the full color
of the offsprings
and it says i'm not interested in
correlation is it i'm interested in the
underlying causal mechanism
and correlation of symmetric
and i'm looking for asymmetric
relationship
so he put down something what was the
innovative and revolutionary at the time
he did not perceive that to be
revolutionary he said that's the way i
think
and the geneticist
this is the way i think
i know that the full color of the
parents guinea pig determine the third
color of the offspring and not the other
way around
so
i will follow my intuition and my
understanding and put down an arrow
an arrow to capture the idea that this
relationship is asymmetric so this was
the first time that causation received a
mathematical or formal voice
before that people thought
asymmetrically you find
us symmetry you find causal relationship
guiding people fought from the ancient
greek from the ancient hebrew
all over
you cannot have a causal talk
a talk
among people without being decorated
with causal notions so obviously um it
shaped their thinking
but it did not receive a
formal notation
and we in computer science
believe that without
notation you don't have science
i have later a quote from de morgan who
said the same thing about formal logic
before bull and morgan he said
the
formal logic
went from one failure to another and has
not advanced much in 2000 years
but
when bull came
and created an algebra for propositional
logic
things took
off
and the same thing happened to causation
before civil right
there wasn't much progress except for
discussion of intuition
from civil right on things took off not
as easily as you expect
because it was a revolution
and civil rights would attack
immediately
by a statistician of the time what are
you doing are you inventing are you
discovering causation from correlation
something that we know it's impossible
and he was
heroically defending his position that
he is not
he's not extracting
causation from correlation but he said
i am extracting causation from two
things
data
plus assumptions which are embedded here
in the path diagram he couldn't pinpoint
his assumptions
he didn't know for for instance that the
lack of arrows is a major assumption the
lack of error from g triple prime to
that guinea pig
is a major assumption he could not
articulate
symbolically the assumptions that he
made in putting down the intuitive path
diagram but he recognized very strongly
that he is making assumptions here that
helps him when combined with data come
up with the undoable
namely coming up with a
causal entities these are the
coefficients that you find here
labeled a
h
and c these are called path coefficients
which he claimed to the rest of his days
heroically
that these are causal coefficients and
not
correlationally defined coefficients
he did not have much success
not even in
genetics
people in social science discover his
papers and
adapted it to social science and he
disappeared from social science he
didn't have much traction in
convincing economists that they should
use his past diagrams to capture the
structural equation
because he came out with a new grammar
anyone who comes with the new grammar is
being shunned
and distanced because because the mind
follows the language and the notation
more than the ideas
so
after paying tribute to civil rights
i will tell you what happened since
civil rights
yeah he is uh
what he
the elements
that
uh
brought us from civil from seawall right
to the modern causal models
are
encapsulated in something which i call
structural causal model
it's the oracle
of all causal statements
and it's rooted in human
intuition
okay
what it is
is the recognition or is it the
perspective of the world as a society
of listeners
namely
every ver every variable
is assigned a value you see here i'm
using the assignment operator
not equality sign
assign a value
which is a function of other variables
in the domain v1 up to vl
plus
some
noise factor
these are
variables that we do not care
to put in our model our choice that we
would like to treat as something
exogenous just give it a valuable a
disturbance term
or exogenous variable or noise term okay
and that is the essence of the
oracle which i'm going to describe to
you in a second
it's a society of listeners
once you have a collection of equations
they determine a graph
a graph is just an abstraction of that
collection of equations
where you put an arrow
between the argument of the function
and
the
variables
which that receives the value
you put an error between those
variables that affect vi
and vi itself so i have a graph defined
by the society okay
now i'm going to show you
how elegant
this entity scm structural causes
mothers
um
how elegant it is
how useful and
how elegant and useful combination of
two things
which allow us to assign
values to every causal sentence
a truth value
this is the first law
of counter faction or the first law of
causal inference
i'm going to
talk about two laws the first one is the
law of counter factions
it is
i found this on the web
is there a question
no no
i heard about uh
[Music]
i couldn't quite hear the question
no question
no but okay
okay
i call it the first law of causal
inference
and
look how neatly in one square you put it
here
and what does it say
it says if you have a model
maybe a collection of functions
like that
you can evaluate all kinds of factual
terms
let me interpret it
the value of variables y
had x been
small x
capital symbols will be the names of
variables small
lowercase symbols will be the values
attached to them now
now i'm going to interpret that in the
following way
the value of variables y
had x been small x okay
for individual u
or under the exogenous variable g o
is equal
to the solution of y in a mutilated
model in which we remove
we mutilate it we remove the
equation for x and replace it by
constant x
so that is interpretation which tells
you how to assign a value to every
counterfactual i'll show you some
examples in a second
but first i want just to
show you
the second
law
and from this too low everything that
i'm going to talk about follows
so you wouldn't need me next year if you
want to do if you want to exercise any
uh
tasks in causal analysis everything
follows from these two
this is a law of conditional
independence also called
different support
this separation
it tells you that every time you find
separation in the graph
it implies
a conditional independence in the data
okay
so i'm going to show you some examples
but
by the way this follows from the first
law
but it's nice to display it separately
because it's something which uh not easy
to prove
let's look at the working of this
first law what does it tell us
it tell us that if i want to find
for instance the value that y will
attain had x being small x okay
all i have to do is to take
my model of the universe my oracle
okay
remove the equation that previously
determine x
replace it by constant x is equal to
small x and solve for y
this value that previously was y
now becomes y sub x this is the
value that y would attain had x been
small x it's extremely simple
see everybody knows how to solve
equations even high school kids knows
how to solve equations which means high
school kids are expert in counterfactual
and they are
else allows them to solve uh questions
in
elementary physics
counterfactuals because they are being
asked questions like
what if the weight of the spring was 3
or 26
they are able to
think kanto factually and replace the
weight from 3 to 26 and resolve the
problem it's a little bit hard for
computer
if we didn't equip the computer with
that schemes
of erasing equations replacing them by
constant and recalculating the value of
y that's all that it says here and i
would like to i summarize this slide by
saying that counterfactuals are
embarrassingly simple
if they weren't embarrassing simple
we wouldn't use control factual in the
language
and we do use it look from
from abraham
to
eratosthenes okay that asks the question
what if there were not 50 righteous
people in sodom okay
can what if cleopatra knows was
differently
what if you didn't smoke
for five years okay we do come
communicate
and we reach consensus in this
communication
so it must be simple
and here i'm going to
propose to you why it is so simple it's
nothing more
than solving a bunch of equations in a
mutilated model
i will go now to the next
and tell you that the same thing applies
to interventions
what is intervention
introversion is a special kind of
counterfactual look at that probability
that y sub x will be equal to small y
okay probability that had x been small x
if i were to smoke
then my life expectancy would be small y
five years okay but looks it's under
a p
it's a probability
that my life expen expectancy will be
five years it's it differs from the
counterfactual in the sense that it's
under the probability
probability sign and not
under the individual side not the value
the actual value of the variables
but the probability of that variable
because it has its unique properties
we
invent a operator called do x
and we are dealing with a do expression
like this
why it is important some people do not
think it's important it's important for
practical reasons we would like to
distinguish
things that we can
um infer
from a randomized experiment
from controlled experiments and things
which
which require
extra information that you couldn't get
from randomized experiment therefore we
invent this symbol do
and that characterizes
all the properties that we can get from
randomized experiments
and distinguish them from other
counterfactuals
that in general need additional
information
so now
that brings me to the ladder of
causation
which is not something that
i propose
but
by my opinion but it's coming from this
definition of counterfactual it's coming
automatically and we observe that we
have here a hierarchy
that goes from association to
intervention to counter fractures
then it's a highway in the sense that
you cannot answer equations hey you
cannot answer questions at level i
unless you have
information
from level i or higher
so if you have a facility
to
intervene
on the world you can answer a question
both in both interventional kind of
question and
associational question but you cannot go
the other way around if you only have
correlation you cannot climb up to
rank number two and answer
interventional questions
if you only have interventional
facilities in the world and you don't
have the imagination that comes with the
scm then you cannot answer
counterfactual question you cannot
answer questions such as what if i have
done things differently or why
why
a certain event happened
was it x that caused y what if x had not
occurred undoing event
what if i had acted differently these
questions cannot be answered if all you
have is intervention on the world okay
if you let the
a
baby or a monkey play around with things
without the ability to store information
of the counterfactual type you wouldn't
be able to answer
question that require
imagination
and the imagination is what i attribute
the
acceleration
that we saw in the development of
science acceleration on the evolutionary
scale scale
that
brought
us from a caveman
to
the scientific revolution that we see
today
i usually use the analogy
with the
snakes and owls that have developed a
very keen
vision vision system
but never
be able to invent an eyeglass or
microscope as we have done in the past
only few hundred years
it took the hours millions of years to
develop its vision system
and it took us only 500 years to develop
the science of optics
so we are in a.i we are after level
three
from level three you can get all the
rest
but it's not easy to climb
the ladder
from level to level there are barriers
bears which are not appreciated in many
fields
in some field
even the climb from association
to intervention
is being doubted
many of the machine learning people
thinks
they can climb this
barrier
from number one to number two
by just being smarter with the data
but this ladder tells you no matter how
smart you are
you need something extra to climb this
ladder this is the ability to actually
intervene on the world
and the same thing from level 2 to level
3
even some epidemiologists
do not believe that you need to
to distinguish them
in a special notation
but
so i don't want to drag you into the
um
disputation that i am involved with this
field i would just like to convince you
that we have here a meaningful burial
that need a push
for climbing
okay
let me now explain to you in greater
details
how to work with the second law
the second law is the law of uh
independence how to read independencies
on in the model
[Music]
yeah that was a part of
a long tradition
uh where is did i say where do you see
the d
in the first uh
it will be
now i'm just saying it quickly
separation but what i mean is
this separation in the literature
it came from directional
separation it's not separation in
undirected graphs it's separation that
takes care of the directionality of the
arrows
it says about three decades long
notation or even
four decades because the bayesian
network
were
formulated
in about 1985
and we needed a word a notation to
distinguish
separation in undirected graph and
separation in directed graph okay so
yeah so it's this separation right
so imagine that you have here
the
structural equation model is a bunch of
equations okay
and
this is a graph that corresponds to that
as you can see these are the variables
that receive arrows or the arguments of
other equations
so we the graph follows
the collection of equation that's very
simple abstraction
now that you have the graph how do you
read
independency in the
every time you have a missing
arrow
it advertises a conditional independence
because a missing error in the graph
advertising
advertises
uh separation
for instance okay i'll go i i'll go
quickly here here's a missing arrow okay
it makes c we separated from w given s
and r
a missing arrow
means a separation
and a separation tells you which
variables will be independent in the
data
so here we
have s and r separating c and w
it tells me that c is independent of w
given s and r in the data
there is a little twist here a missing
arrow between s and r
it tells me that
s is separated from r
given c and w
but here the collider it has its own
rule i wouldn't get into it it's a
technical details of how to handle
collider i know it if i know the rules
it tells me that s and r are independent
given c
not given c and w
it's just a little technical details of
how to handle a colliders
that head to head arrows
but let's go back and ask ourselves
okay
why i call it a miracle
because
look how audacious
this theorem is
it says that if the user independent i
don't show the user i just imagine them
to impinge on every every variable has
its noise factor noise factor noise
factor u c u s u r uw
it tells me
that as long as the u's are independent
the observed distribution
namely p of c r s w
must satisfy the constraints and these
constraints are independent
on the nature of the functions here
no matter how crazy function you load it
with and no matter what the probability
distribution that you attribute to the
impinging noise okay these independents
are going to be expected to hold in the
distribution if your model is correct of
course right
and they are readable from the graph
it takes about
[Music]
five minutes to computer scientist to
learn it
it takes
50 years for an economist to learn it
but um
this is
this is the world we live in
okay
um
but it's such a useful device that
without which it it's so useful that i
labeled the second law okay
and it's it's a miracle that we have
this
why because we can do so much with that
what can we do with that
applications
model testing
if the data turns out not to satisfy
the conditional independencies that the
model dictates
which means that something is wrong with
my model
so i can test the model and overrule it
and discard it and repair it okay
number two what i can do is
structure learn
i can think about this set of all models
that are compatible with the data i do
observe or with the conditional
independences that i do observe in my
data
and i look at a set of compatible models
and i can perhaps find a nice
personalized representation for the set
then i can ask questions about the set
rather than individual
model
and sometimes the answer that i get from
the set will be satisfactory
and sufficient for the kind of questions
i want to answer and this is the idea
of structural learning which is one of
the pillars of wisdoms
so
i can i will show you soon that i can
induce interventional question
to statistical adjustment
using the correlation that i found in
the data
and more important for us is reducing
intervention pressure to symbolic
calculus
and that is the function of
the do calculus which allows you to
answer questions about intervention
just by an analytically
like like like an algebra
like solving equations in algebra
or like doing a
integration
symbolic integration
okay let's we are ready to go into the
do calculus
and look at one of the working halls of
this exercise
and this is the back door criterion okay
it tells you that
if you want to find the causal effect of
an action do x on y
it is estimable
whenever you find a set of
variables z
that
blocks
all the path
all the backdoor paths between the x and
the y
okay
why is that
because
what does it mean
if i do x
i mean if i chopped off the equation or
the arrows going from x parents to x
and i look at my remaining graph i can
accomplish the same thing
by
blocking
the spurious correlation path
along these arrows
from x to y
all the spirits the non-causal
[Music]
path from x to y if i chop them if i
block them by adjusting by observation i
can accomplish the same thing
so therefore
i look at my graph and say what if i
observe z1 and z4 i can look at
whether or not
i have
managed to block all the
spurious correlation between x and y
or not
if i do
i say yes
the causal effect is estimable by simple
adjustment
so that can do with s from z4 and z5
and so i can tell
just by looking at the graph
which covariance i need to adjust for
if i need to estimate a causal effect
so without doing any
without doing any
physical intervention i can look at the
graph and say i can simulate
intervention
by
simple statistical adjustment
and give you the answer that you would
have gotten had you run a controlled
rise
control run to my experiment on x okay
here is an example in mo
and what what's the answer here's the
answer
the answer to my question what y would
be
had i done x would be
a
do free expression not do
no intervention it just has conditional
probabilities in it
i
i condition on z
and i sum
i took a weighted sum given the prior
probability of z
these are available to me
from
for my data
right
the probability of z
and the conditional probability of any
variable on any set of variables is
available to me in the data i can
compute it therefore
i can infer
an interventional
expression
form a statistical expression
using this technique
it's called adjusting for z
this is something that was an obstacle
to statistician
from the time
from a time of fisher
and
the question of which
which confounders
you should adjust for to deconfound
your system
has been a stumbling block for many
years and it received a full
uh formulation now
using this
simple idea
of this separation of backdoor criteria
okay
in more practical
application
i'll give you an example from uh
from
medical
from sport medicine okay
in sport medicine
the question of whether warm up exercise
causes injury
or prevent injury
is still debatable
and you have many if you ask a
sport physician
what are the factors
that are comes to mind
he or she will plot this kind of network
so here you have here the question is
what should i measure some of them are
very hard to measure some of them are
easy
some of them if you measure them and you
incorporate them you'll get the wrong
result obvious result the answer is
simple just look at the graph and you
get the answer
if you if you manage to
pressure
z1 and z2 you are done
if you manage to
measure
intra game
proprioception
and z1 you are done
it's okay thou shall not adjust for
previous injury no no it is a collider
which will give you a wrong result and
so on so it all boils down to a
mathematics
it's no longer
at the mercy of human intuition
which was until
the causal revolution now it becomes a
matter of mathematics you take your
intuition you consult it this is your
scientific knowledge of a domain
but you're putting down the way you
present it in your mind
okay easy the way you that comes to your
mind
now you
proposing to the mathematics department
you send it over and ask them what
should i do and the rest is
formal analysis no longer rely on
intuition
okay
i want to show you how you go beyond
adjustment
here's an example
of a domain
and a problem
that cannot be solved by adjustment
we it's a famous problem of smoking
power and cancer
suppose we are given
a possibility of measuring the tile
accumulated in the lung of a patient
whether or not the patient smoked
whether or how long he took to develop
cancer right so we have information only
about the three variables smoking tar
and cancer
and we suspect however
that there is a genotype which is
unobserved
which make people crave for nicotine
at the same time puts them in a cancer
risk yeah
so this is the unobserved genotype
problem that official
argue must exist and we shouldn't rely
on the on the correlation that we
observe between smoking and cancer and
the question is how can we solve a
problem like that and there is no
variable that we can adjust for
that will comply with the demand of the
of the backdoor criterion
okay
there is no such a
variable
t or z
that if i just for
will block all the back door path
between smoking and cancer here is a
backdoor path that is not blockable
because it goes through an unobserved
hidden variable
but
it can be done
by
pure algebra
here is how the algebra goes
going to give you only the flavor not
the detail the flavor goes like that
this is my query you see
p of cancer
given that i do
smoking or do not smoking
this is my query
and i want what is my input
the data gives me the probability of
three variables
joint probability of three variables
i want to be able to answer the query
using my data
namely i want to
be able to convert
my data
into expression
which is do expression
or the other way around i can i want to
be able to convert my query
into expression which involves only
conditional independencies among the on
my uh that i can obtain for my data
it's doable
this way okay
i have
again forgive the details
that's just the flavor the flavor is
that we have
rules of
combination
rule of transformation that we can
transform an expression
involving do and c
to other
such
sentences
and the
transformation is valid if a certain
condition in the graph holds these are
the license given
and i'm
going through every exercise in pure
logic
can i convert this to this and the
answer is yes i'll
go one rule by rule and tell you if the
rule is satisfied given the condition in
the graph
and so
now i have a a proof
what we normally in computer science
will call a proof
okay
that it's doable
and this is the answer
that you get but look at the answer it
has no do operator i got rid of the do's
and i got an answer which contains only
conditional probabilities which i can
experiment i can
estimate one by one and multiplying some
or i can send it to the machine learning
department
and ask him have you ever seen saturn
expression in your life
can you perhaps give it to a lasso kind
of algorithm that will find a quick and
unbiased estimate of this kind of
entity
from finite data that's important here
to get the maximum power you have to
minimize variance
the idea is that with the algebra which
we have here we find an expression that
emulates our intervention and we can
think about
machine learning exercise that will give
us an estimator for this
kind of estimate as demand is what you
wish to estimate
okay just as that is the flavor of the
do calculus these are the three rules of
the do calculus
you can
give you a license to ignore an
observation
a license to change observation to an
action
interchange doozy z if something holds
in the graph analyzing to ignore action
altogether
if something holds in the graph
these are the three rules
and it turns out that this
calculus is complete
complete in computer science
sense what does it mean it means that if
the algorithm
fails
to give you an answer
then no one can do better
it means that the answer does not exist
which means that the query is not
estimable given the ex the assumption
that you have in your model
and that the model must be refined
that no observation must be taken or new
um links
must be
invented
or no of a new intervention must be
stipulated
model must be refined and no one can do
better
so no machine learning person can tell
you
that he or she is smarter and can climb
the ladder and give you an answer to
your quick
interventional query
it's just
undoable
and that's very important
be able to determine that your model is
insufficient
saves you hours and hours of
feudal efforts
the idea for instance in the
linear
linear algebra
the idea that you cannot solve the
three equations with four unknown
has saved
humankind hours and hours of trials
right
it was extremely
useful at the time and this is what is
useful in our time
okay
at this point
i'm going to go to the second part of my
agenda and i'm going to talk about
the new what the new science adds to ai
one by one will tackle those seven
pillars of causal wisdom
the first pillar we already seen
to combine oh no
sorry
i don't know how i jump to that
okay i have a seven pillars and i see
the slide the slide here only goes to
some of them
forgive me
okay look at the data fusion problem
that's one of the tasks
that has been
a stumbling block
both in machine learning
and in many sciences how to combine
results from several experiments
or observational studies
each conducted on a different population
and under different set of conditions
and come out with an answer
so as to construct a valid estimate
of effect size in yet a new population
and must match by any of those observed
those studied okay
i
i will put it in a
medical terms in a second just to show
you the complexity
of that problem how important it is and
how
undoable it is to the human mind
imagine that you take
hospital data from various hospitals
your job is to find the
effect size
in arkansas
based on data taking in hospitals and
different
areas
you took a study in new york it was a
survey data
and you took a in los angeles which was
on a younger population
he
got data from another hospital in boston
which was mostly about successful
lawyers
this is what boston
is famous for right
and
in san francisco
it was uh
you notice
post treatment
that
patients who will
selected for the trial had high
especially high blood pressure
and then you you also got information
from texas
which was mostly on spanish-speaking
subject
and they had high attrition which means
not all of them followed
the study some of them dropped
this is very much like the problem we
had today in the past two years with the
covered 19.
we had information from
various countries
some of them were careful about the data
some of them actually manipulated the
data for political reasons
and
the data came from different population
under different conditions
and we had to put it all together
and come out with a
answer to a query what about spain
should they be vaccinated or not
well
you can see the enormity of the problem
and it's indeed undoable
to the human mind
but it's doable if you have the
mathematics to do that so here it is
up sorry i still have more three more
hospitals okay
never never mind
it's complex enough even without those
so forget about the hospitals and let's
look at them from a mathematical
viewpoint
zoop this is what you do
if you
informalize it
and you assume that the disease is
essentially it has followed the same
structure it's just the condition change
so this s variable
is
it's called uh
forgot what we call it here yeah it has
a name
we just call it s variable it is
selection variable it tells you how one
environment
different from another one if i put an s
variable into z i say this environment
is suspected of having
different type of these these people
than these other than this this is a
target
so here different variables receive
the alarm variable telling them you
might be different
there should be a disparity between the
w measured here and the w measured in
your target population
it designates where disparity might come
from
but the idea of the algebra is to
extract the commonalities among them
putting the commonalities together and
come up with an answer to the query
what can you say about the effect size
in arkansas which you never visited
before
you don't have any data coming from all
you have is stipulated structure
and the algebra is available so i'm just
telling you a summary
of the accomplishment of this study in
what we call transportability
or fusion
and the summary goes like that
transportability
can be determined
provided with commonalities and
differences are encoded in selection
diagrams like the one that i showed you
before
the s variable is a selection s
and
when it is feasible
you can extract a transport formula
that can be derived in polynomial time
transport formula tells you
what data to take from what studies
and how to put them together to get the
answer to the query
right
and that in polynomial time and again
something else which shouldn't be under
appreciated the algorithm is complete
which means if the answer is
if the algorithm
comes comes up within
with a failure
i cannot do it
it means that it cannot be done
if you don't have enough data or in
sufficiently refined studies something
must be done
so this is what we call data fusion
selection bias is another exercise
within the data fusion
scheme
but it has to do with the fact
that in
most
trials
and in most experimental studies
the people who volunteer for the study
are different than the people who are
actually going to use
the recommendation of the study
normally you entice people to come and
volunteer for the study
financially you tell them you're going
to get
days off work
or you're going to be actually
incentivized incentivized by the money
real money
and if you are homeless
you are more likely to volunteer to the
study than if you have a good paying job
okay which means you have a selection of
bias
in your studies
which cannot be
gotten rid of
by randomization
randomization doesn't cure selection
studies you are stuck with it okay
i recently
said that we all we all live in this in
a selection by the world our universe is
select is biased prone
because we are not the one who decides
what data we look at it's nature that
occasionally spits out data at us or
enables us to conduct experiments but no
we are not the masters of what we want
to interrogate in nature but never mind
the philosophy let's go let's go down to
nitty gritty
again it's the same
scheme
you put down on paper
what you want to find and you put down
what you do have
the kind of
results you get from your studies
whether it is
bias
with selection or not and what you in
yeah okay
and then you
submit it to the algebra and the algebra
grind through and gives you an answer
is it estimable or not and if it is
how do you estimate it
so the theorem is
if you are if your query is such
that you can
we can transform it
such at all do expression
our condition on
s and all do free expression
uh
not condition on s
then your query is
uh
[Music]
and then you can recover
from selection buyers even if such
buyers exist okay i'll show you an
example and why it is
because you don't want any
s
you don't want any s to appear
in
next to a do
okay
because you don't have information
about
the people who are selected
to the buyers this is not part of your
query you want to query about the target
population in which
no preferential treatment no
preferential selection took place so you
forbid the s from appearing
in the do
expression
at the same time
all the do expression should be
conditionalness because this is where
you conduct your study you conduct your
experiment and your intervention on
people who volunteered for the study s
is equal to one okay so
the algebra takes care of those
considerations and save you well they
hard thinking about
who was selected why was it selected and
so forth you just submitted to the
algebra the algebra grind through and
give you an answer here's an example
nope
here's the model
you want to find
the causal effect on the population at
large there's no s here
you have only data
given s
between you are getting
study on the homeless people that were
selected for the studies
can you get rid of this
yes
two application of the rules of do
calculus allows you to accomplish what
we said in the condition for
the for recovery
and so how
first one
gets rid of the do replace it by x
the second one
supplement this expression with x
because it is conditionally independent
given z see
from y
we are done
two application of the do calculus rules
and allow you to satisfy
the
conditions for recoverability from
selection bias and zoop the answer is
yes and here is the answer
okay
it's not a judge review
without an algorithm i leave you with
the answer
thou shall take this conditional in
conditional probability
from
[Music]
from a data at large
multiplied by this conditional
probability which is given to you from
the study combine them that way and this
is your answer
i'm going now to personal medicine which
is another
trick
it comes not from it i didn't list it
among the seven pillars
because
that was uh
it requires the counterfactual reasoning
yeah it is part of it but it didn't
emphasize it
so what is it in personal medicine and
what is in all
situation based
decision making
normally
when people tells you
i want to do personalized medicine
what they mean is i want to find
a set of characteristics of the
individual
and i'm going to
look at the
pro sub population
that resemble in the region the most
so i'm going to do
a study on a population i call it
average
treatment effect
it gives you the difference between
acting one and acting zero
given a set of characteristics c
which resemble the individual in
question
this is eight
but that is not what really we are after
we are after the individual itself
we want to find out
the probability
that the individual will be cured
if given a treatment one
and will suffer or will die
will not be cured
if denied treatment
zero
given is characteristic this is a
counterfactual term
which cannot be estimated even in
a randomized controlled trial
because it deals with individual itself
it has the values
difference between two kind of behavior
that and that
they cannot be measured at the same time
i have an n sign here a logical end
i want to have a conjunction here
between two
events that cannot occur together in the
physical world
but luckily we have account of actual
logic
the counterfactual logic can supplement
what we cannot do in the real world
and
we can
bound
that quantity which i called probability
of necessary and sufficient okay the
treatment was necessary and sufficient
for this particular individual we cannot
estimate it but we can bound it
and sometimes the bounds can be
sufficiently informed as to direct your
decision
better than what you do if you have
population data if you base everything
in population and this is what i
currently believe is a future of
personalized medicine
we have perfected this idea
in the past two years
into various applications
but
you should we should all understand
that we cannot with randomized control
trial
give an answer to this question why
suppose we find there's no effect in a
randomized trial we don't know if no
individual was affected
or if the treatment cured some and
killed others
the difference between no effect on any
individual
and kill some and kill others cannot be
determined from a randomized controlled
trial
this gives you an average on the
population
but doesn't give you any idea about
individual and the logic of
counterfactual does give you that
additional ingredient
okay here's a summary
the probability of resistant sufficient
is not in generally identifiable but can
be bound
and the bound can be improved by
combination
of what
by combining observational and
experimental studies
the example will be
i i'll demonstrate to you
for a notion for legal notion called but
fall
okay
thou shalt pay compensation in personal
liability cases
for misconduct
or bad the product
if the jury can
prove that the
the plaintiff
would have died would not have died
had
but for the action
of the defendant
here's an example
your honor
my client mr died because he took he
used his drug so the drug manufacturer
is responsible to pay compensation to
the family of the disease
okay
now
the court isn't instructed
by the rule of law i didn't invent it
to decide
if the if it's more probable than not
that mr a would be alive but for the
drug
this is how
the court of law
articulate the criterion
for guilty or innocent
and now you can see it has two elements
it has a probability element
and it has a counterfactual element but
four
how do we articulate it mathematically
being
probably of necessity
the guy would be alive
had he had no drug
given that in fact he is dead
and he took the drug so you can see why
we call it counterfactual there's a
conflict between what we see he's dead
and here we are asking would you be
alive okay we have a conflict between
the condition
we are between the observation
and the query okay
if we didn't have control factor the
answer will be come on it's
impossible but we have counterfactual so
see how we raise it and the code demand
that this probability will be greater
than 50 percent more probable than not
okay
well sometimes we are lucky
and we by combining observational data
with
experimental data
we are lucky to have a point estimate
for this quantity which normally is only
bound
and here's the case
up
oh no
i don't want it
i want
okay
we are lucky enough to have a guilty
verdict
when the pro the bounds
happen to be
reduced to a point estimate around one
see
combined data can tell us more than each
individual alone
this is only for
a certain combination of experimental
um i i crafted it in such a way so that
i'll get a bound of one
okay or a point estimate of one
just to be happy with the guilty
verdict okay
but in in general
will have a bounce and if the lower
bound is above 50
then the verdict of guilty
should according to the court of law be
issued
good
i uh before we continue i
i want to read you some of the questions
because we're at the time already that
i i don't want people to go away before
you answer their questions okay okay uh
on this part
yeah i'll be happy to answer questions
on this yeah
no it's it's about the whole talk it's
just that we are at the time where the
questions are
i'm worried that some people go away
before the questions
okay
so there's a question from julius from
google
[Music]
and he says uh i have two questions
regarding the ladder of causation
do you think is this
um as a true discrete hierarchy or
rather as a continuous spectrum for
example where would something like
partial identification of counter and
factual queries based on observational
intervention data fit in and the second
part of the question is do you think the
hack is complete or may there be a need
for an additional force
for example something like actual
causation fit in
with one fruit
good question good question i'll go to
the right i think that this is the
the hierarchy is discrete
we we find a very
clear
um
barrier
between the levels and i don't see how
they can be smeared
by condition
what can smear them
they evolve as a discrete from the
structural causal model
okay
i i i don't know the mechanism that can
make them
uh be uh
continuous
but anyhow if you have
did you have any
suggestion of what can make them smooth
what can make the transition
from one level to i'll go back to the
ladder maybe it's not too hard so maybe
this is something
the person who asked the question can
actually speak uh so maybe that's
something for
him to write to you directly
fear suggestions but there's another
question here by issa caller can i say
and she says can data analysis
also produce non-causal explanation
it gives rise to being in control
for example a child learns not just that
turning the switch on causes the light
and switch on causes the light to turn
on but also that the thing on the wall
is of the type switch and why how does
that type of understanding fit into a
framework
make a strong case for why ai will not
be smart unless it can operate with
something like functional cause of
knowledge but what about non-causal
understanding e.g understanding that a
particular written text is a contract
because of offer acceptance and
consideration
so isa is a from a last call
yeah this kind of uh understanding
that we normally find in machine
learning
when we understand why the system has
given you a yes answer or no answer
why you got the answer what made the
system produce the answer it did it's a
different kind of understanding
that we have in causal reasoning we're
asking for a
a why question that relates to the
outside world
why the world operate the way it is
okay not why the system has been
fooled or to give you an answer yes or
no
why this
the machine learning system has given
you an answer is not an explanation
that's an explanation of why
the originals came out with that
recommendation but it's not an
explanation of why
you should not receive
why your
loan application was refused
if
yeah
the next question is uh
do you have any examples of
transportability
and selection bias algorithms being
applied to real data in scientific
literature
can you repeat it
do you have examples of transportability
and selection bias algorithms
are being applied to real data in the
scientific literature
oh
it's a difficult question
i
in my laboratory we do not do not do
real data what is called real data
we
we see our job as transforming
the attitude and the mindset
of researchers in other fields
those who are expert in real data
we have been very unsuccessful
to convert
economists to this way of thinking
but we were very successful
to convert the mindset of
epidemiologists
at least somebody counted there are 200
papers in epidemiology that are using
the causal inference here
actually i'm not aware
of a
study with real dirty data about
transportability i'm not aware
but i
and i'm not even conducting research
because i i don't want to defend myself
by so-and-so
adapting
this system or changing his mind this is
not my criteria for success
my criterion is i can do something today
that i could not do yesterday
this is my criteria for success
whether people
fall into it or not
i hope they do
okay
and
and i hope we'll see more and more
transportability kind of exercises
than in with real data
because
right now i don't even know
of a single i cannot name
huh
yeah
okay i can name some
exercises in the econo economics
it had to do with
recovering from selection of buyers but
they were done wrong
so i
so we have the data and we have the
mindset of good people and the time is
right to implement it
that's all i can tell you
excellent and the rest of the questions
are all huge compliments
saying that great talk they want to
connect with anyone who's applying your
work just work on ai projects or
research
and uh you have a huge following here
who wants to connect with you and others
oh i exceeded my time no i can't do that
because i have to talk about the blue
sky
okay so why don't you
head to the blue sky okay
blue sky
okay
oh okay that's very important i i it's
not blue sky but it's very important
because everybody asked me
and what if i don't have a money
okay
i i was educated in machine learning in
statistics when i believe that
everything can be gotten from data okay
my answer to that you should still study
structural causal model because in many
applications we can't wait
for evolution to take place
the data requirement to go through
millions of years of evolution okay is
to sparse
and we have a lot of variable
valuable
knowledge in the skulls of
bio statistician epidemiology that we
must
bring to bear
so one
element is urgency expediency we can't
wait
second one you still have to study sem
why to help you find one if you don't
have a model
it's very hard to find a needle in a
haystack but it's doubly hard if you
haven't seen a needle before right so
i'm giving you about the needle you're
looking for okay
and i have another reason why you should
study sms
once you get it once you get the
knowledge
that is needed
if you get it from data or from some
tricks fine but once you have it you
have to know how to use it you have to
know how to store it so you can answer
questions that's why you have to study
sem
and the fourth one is don't forget you
have to explain things to a human user
so the explanation that you provide
are gonna be must be cast in the
language which is meaningful to the end
user and the end user is doing scm
end user is not using i mean not
thinking in terms of neural architecture
the neural architecture is what guides
the user inside but the language that
the user would like to communicate and
get an answer in is the language of
cause and effect
okay i got him so now we go to the blue
sky
and let me just tell you about
social intelligence this is something
you want to capture in the next
uh
few years
the idea of
now we have
an understanding of what understanding
is
namely we have a model of a system that
understand a domain
why shouldn't we use it
to find an understanding
of a software of another agent
so if we have a blueprint of a software
of another agent
we can
[Music]
talk we can
talk about one agent understanding
another
and come out with a definition
an algorithm
that will enable them to talk in terms
of
notions such as trust
desires
responsibility
awareness intention motivation so one
agent tells the other trust me
you you see that i like that i i
understand
your desires
i've helped you in the past i'm going to
help you again i know your values
i know your motivations
trust me
i proved myself in the test
and that is what i mean by social
intelligence is communication among
agent using this notion i just had a
look into a stanford encyclopedia to see
what morally responsible is
and look what we find here
there is a causal connection between
asian action and outcome
the agent must have a control over the
outcome
agent must have a knowledge of
be able to consider consequences of an
action it all boils down to
notions that we know how to formulate
today
using the causal models
freely choose is a hard one also
knowledge is a hard one because knowing
things explicitly is totally different
than knowing things implicitly okay i
know how to play chess but i don't know
the best first move in chess
okay so this is the blue sky i'll end
with a statement
with the recognition of gary king
that we went through a revolution
in the causal inference
which is equal to the sum total of
everything that has been learned
throughout recorded history that's a
very sweeping kind of
statement
and i have complemented with my own
statement that this is nothing compared
with what you're going to see in the
next few years okay
when we interpret we realize
that we need the data science is the
science of interpreting reality
not of summarizing data
this is my
the end
i like to end with august de morgan
statement that every sign
that has thriven
has driven upon its own symbols
not by boring symbols from other signs
and a commercial on the book of why
if you read this book then i communicate
with you
you may teach me but i cannot
ela i cannot communicate
and being taught but what i need to do
now if you haven't read the book of y
thank you
okay i'm ready for
question answers now okay uh you know so
i i i went to some of the questions i
want to read you one more comment and
then uh somebody people in the audience
will ask so one more comment is that we
need a forum for causal scientists to
gather and collaborate presentation was
awesome and so glad to find other
like-minded people it's time for kosali
to leave the conference about india
and find penetration into every day's
business life crap club okay and now uh
please uh you have a question from the
audience
thank you so much i had high
expectations yeah and high expectations
for the the talk and they're
certainly being met
uh i had another question on the
ladder of
so my question was how do you know or
prove that animals or
or babies um
their inability to do the third level of
the latter isn't just a limitation due
to language like you can't ask a baby to
to do counterfactuals because they can
talk to you yeah or same same thing with
monkeys and other animals or is this a
stupid question because language perhaps
is what enables us to do
counterfactuals in the first place
[Music]
it's a good question i don't have an
answer for
it's hard to speculate of what babies do
whether
a task performed by babies belongs to
each one of the rungs of the ladder it's
very hard although i know that
alison
gopnik has done work on that
babies
can do counterfactual
playing the game of uh make believe yeah
let's make believe
that we are playing this game
let's make believe that you are the king
and i'm the queen okay this is a form of
counterfactuals and babies
evidently do very well in make-believe
but
i i don't have
a an answer to that question how do we
find out
we need to
to have a better
understanding of what tasks can be
performed only if you have the ability
to do counterfactuals
because obviously generating explanation
requires a language okay
but it's his ability to repair things
requires counter fracture
if i turn the
the lights on
and the light doesn't turn if i turn the
switch on the light doesn't turn on i'm
thinking about how i can repair it
perhaps the light bulb needs to be
replaced okay
so the age at which babies learn that
they can repair
things by switching by to buying a new
light bulb
and or thinking maybe there was a power
surge
and maybe i didn't pay my bill to the
department of
water and power okay
that kind of repairs
it takes i think
we can look to what degree animals can
repair
unexpected happenings
things that
are abnormal
which do not operate according to
expectation
this is one clue that we may have
ability to repair things uh as an
indication that they are engaged in
counterfactual reasoning
and i don't think monkey can monkeys can
repair things to a certain extent but
not the way we do it
so that's the only one indication
another one it was to look at the
evolution of culture
and see whether
a different
development of tools
and
of tools
are accompanied
with the development of counterfactual
thinking of language of the subjunctive
mode in the language had he done things
thank you i think here's the last
question
which is more particular it says that in
your smoking and cancer
directed the graph
um see the graph you had the arrows
flowing from smoking to cancer
what if your model had them going in the
other direction how do you decide which
model is more appropriate
uh well i
everything here is
based on your scientific knowledge
okay
well there are tests
of course a model can be ruled out
i've shown you
incompatibility with the data
there's also incompatibility with a set
of experiments so if you conduct
experiments of the rare scans and we
know precisely what experiment should
rule out what model
but otherwise when you start i cannot
rule out the idea that the
cancer caused smoking
but i started with the idea that the
cancer that they have a common
inherences here
in this example
we allowed for some common cause
to cause both craving for nicotine and
cancer if you have a feedback loop it
cancer itself
makes you depressed
and
drives you to smoking
then you have a feedback loop right
between cancer and smoking
and you have a cycle
structural causal model works for cycle
as well
as long as you have only
one
one
equation for variable
so if you have a
arrow going from cancer to smoking
smoking still has one set of parents
it's not gonna okay so the scm
in its
semantic
articulation allows for cycles okay
you cannot use the do calculus
to answer the question because the two
calculus assume that you have a bag
directed are sickly grabbed
but you can use then you have to go back
to
harder calculus which i haven't mastered
and i haven't developed which allows
cycles and then it goes straight into
the structural causal muscle with the
functions there okay
in my book causality i have two
exercises with cycles
an answer come to factual queries with
cycles
demand and price
controlling each other
thank you very much it's an amazing talk
i wish we had more time
because i think we missed on some of the
sides in the in your
a lot to think about and i think the
audience and thank you for
the audience and especially for you to
take the time and this fantastic
occasion thank you very much well thank
you all for being with me
and for listening so patiently
thank you
hey
stop here
bye bye